Droht eine weltweite epidemie durch vogelgrippe
Am vogelgrippevirus h 79 sind mehr als 1600 menschen erkrankt etwa 40 prozent davon sind verstorben
Jetzt hat ein japanisches forschungsteam erschreckendes über diese virusvariante herausgefunden sie erfüllt fast alle
Voraussetzungen für eine pandemie also für eine gigantische weltweite epidemie die ihn auch vor grenzen kann
Halt macht warum die erreger mittlerweile noch viel gefährlicher geworden sind und was getan wird um eine vogelgrippe pandemie zu verhindern
Also wie ist die lage jetzt den klicks um science-fiction herzlich willkommen
Direkt mal vorab die vogelgrippe ist nichts neues und vogelgrippe ist auch nicht gleich vogelgrippe schon seit tausenden von jahren befallen viren wildvögel und hausgeflügel
Doch mittlerweile gibt es nach angaben von experten und expertinnen mindestens 15 verschiedene varianten der erkrankung die virusvariante
H7 n9 ist im jahr
2013 das erste mal in china aufgetaucht die erkrankten hatten sich damals alle durch den direkten kontakt
Mit geflügel angesteckt eine übertragung von mensch zu mensch ist bislang noch nicht möglich viele der patienten und patientinnen leiden an schweren
lungenentzündung und fieber
infizierte tiere dagegen sind nicht unbedingt sichtbar krank mittlerweile haben sich die virusvarianten
weiterentwickelt und zwar mit
Weitreichenden folgen für uns für ihre studie hat das forschungsteam aus tokio virus proben von einem chinesischen patienten der anfang
2017 an der vogelgrippe verstorben war genauer untersucht und dabei haben sie gleich drei erschreckende entdeckung gemacht zum einen
fanden sie in dieser probe unterschiedliche varianten des erregers
Das fatale daran nicht alle von ihnen sprechen auf die wirkstoffe an die die vermehrung des virus blockieren
im klartext heißt das also dass einige der viren bereits resistent sind gegen gängige grippemittel
Im detail handelt es sich um sogenannte
neuraminidasehemmer die wie gesagt normalerweise
zuverlässig verhindert haben dass sich die erreger vermehrten zudem stellten die wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler fest dass es sich bei dem identifizierten
erreger um einen sogenannten hochpathogenen
subtyp das h7 neuen virus handelt bei den vorherigen epidemien war dagegen niedrig pathogene viren
Im spiel also kurze erklärung der begriff pathogen kommt aus dem griechischen
patras verladen und gehen für erzeugen mit dieser bezeichnung
wird also grob gesagt die gefährlichkeit
des erregers eingestuft und auch das dritte experiment des japanischen forschungsteams zeigt deutlich dass wir diese instrumente erreger keinesfalls
unterschätzen dürfen wenn versuche im labor zeigten dass das thema simon virus tatsächlich gelingt sich erfolgreich in menschlichen zellen der atemwege
zu vermehren das bedeutet nichts gutes denn das ist tatsächlich die erste voraussetzung
Dafür dass die so genannte arten schranken überwunden wird ja also glücklicherweise
Gelingt dies der resistenten varianten nicht so gut wie den nicht resistenten virus formen in einem weiteren test
klärten die forscherinnen und forscher auch die zweite voraussetzung für die überwindung der arten schranke nämlich optimieren auch zwischen
säugetieren übertragbar sind und tatsächlich die mit h 79 infizierten frettchen
hatten die gesunden frettchen in den nachbar käfigen angesteckt und zwar via tröpfcheninfektion also
Mit atem wenn sie mit der nicht resistenten wäre variante infiziert waren starben die tiere
In den meisten fällen das forschungsteam schlägt jetzt alarm denn diese studie zeigt dass es nur noch eine frage der zeit ist bis sich eine
Besonders gefährliche virusvariante entwickelt zitat bis jetzt ist zwar noch keine übertragung von mensch, zu mensch
dokumentiert worden doch offenbar verbreitet sich das h7 wir uns schon heute zwischen zeuge tier
Passt es sich weiter an könnten daraus bald erreger mit pandemie potenzial hervorgehen warnt einer der beteiligten forscher
Yoshikawa opa der worst case also eine erregervariante die sich besonders
effektiv in menschlichen zellen vermehrt resistent gegen gängige grippemittel ist und somit ein tödliches potenzial hat die
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler fordern jetzt dass man die entwicklung
Des virus ganz genau unter beobachtung hält und das geschieht sehr schnell bislang ist ja eine übertragung von mensch
zu mensch noch nicht möglich doch dies ist nach ansicht des forschungsteams
vielleicht nur noch eine frage der zeit denn bereits vor vier jahren zeigte sich dass die erreger sich rasend
schnell an ihrem neuen wirte anpassen zudem sei es dringend notwendig neue medikamente gegen die resistenten
virusvarianten zu entwickeln dafür schlagen sie auch gleich einen konkreten wirkstoff vor den rna polymerase hemmer
Habib ära wir wenn er kein video zu diesem thema auch
Zu allen anderen themen verpassen wollt dann drückt mir hier ein abo aufsaugen vergesst nicht den
Genau auf die glocke nur dann werdet ihr auch
Aktuell auf dem stand zu diesem thema und zu allen anderen themen gehalten hier also hier geht es weiter mit etwas ganz anderem
Sexuelle anziehung musik macht männer attraktiver da ist musik drin also viel spaß dabei und ansonsten bis dann
bleibt dran